I might not be the guy for you
because I just feel like I kind of lost
that that spark we had in paradise
after leaving Neil broke up with
Annalise in front of everyone blindsided
her did you guys see that coming and
what was your reaction I think my
reaction was oh that sucks
it really sucks friend Elise I really
like Annalise she's a wonderful woman
big heart and it just really hurt me
because right before all that that
segment we were talking she's like I'm
so excited to see Camille now I don't
know Camille and it's not my job to sit
up here and judge him on what he does
and on on his choices but I would just
say that maybe if you if you were to
watch this maybe you would realize that
there's a better way to do that she just
you know she she's just too good of a
girl to have to go through that and I
really feel bad for her
how bad was that I just think you know
like where your morals like where do you
stand as a person like for you to do
that and just like drag that
relationship right up to that point that
takes a lot that takes a lot it's been a
few months like it just makes she's
better off you know for someone that
hasn't innum to do something like that
like it's better that he does something
now like that then in the future maybe
when their relationship was more just
just to think that he led her on allowed
her to just need to make plans after
this yeah some questionable things but I
don't think that he's the brightest
yeah that was bad yeah I wasn't I don't
know I don't know I would I mean I wish
you would've did it off-camera but I
felt like he was dying to say it so I
mean he probably should have just said
it a while ago when he really felt it I
was just cringing through all of that I
remember looking up and I'm like biting
my fist and I was like don't do this
don't do this and he kept dragging it
out and dragging out and you look over
at Annalise and she's like breaking down
internally I think he could have handled
it so much better
all he all he needed was to have a
conversation like even two days prior
and for some reason he had to wait and
like do this in front of everybody
watching that was painful to watch
you
[Music]